just as we contemplate a return to
lockdown
the safety nets of the last one are
being pulled away
soon furlough will wind up and today the
ban
on evictions ended many of those who
lost their income during the virus
now face losing their homes how is any
of this
my fault um should i just sleep on the
street
such as musician astrid with gigs
cancelled
she can't keep up things and was served
with an eviction warning this week
realistically the only option i could
see is
maybe moving with a friend for a bit
until
things change but i don't know who that
friend would be
so we're basically facing becoming
homeless
yeah i've been
on the verge of a lot of stuff
during this pandemic i've had many
thoughts that i wish i didn't have
and they were instigated by the emails
from the agency and the pressure to pay
rent debt that i can't pay off
if i'm losing money and loads of people
are losing money
why shouldn't the landlord
be affected by that anyone served with
an eviction notice since the end of
august has a six-month notice period but
those served before that
don't and it's estimated there's a
backlog of 55 000
cases but that will build according to
the homeless charity shelter
375 000 people are in rent arrears
and the vast majority of them weren't
before lockdown
but landlords say they've been generous
during the crisis it's majority cases
and
you know they've agreed to write off
their entrees and then reduce the rent
that's yeah that's helpful to the
tenants but already there's resistance
in a block in stoke newington
a number of residents served with
notices say if necessary
they'll resist eviction we're hoping
they'll agree
that it's better if we kind of wind down
this campaign and they let us stay in
our homes and they work with tenants who
are struggling to pay
but if it comes to it and they send the
bailiffs after us then yeah we'll
probably have to do something like
have people standing up in front of the
door and saying no to anyone who tries
to kick us out
this demonstration organized by
political group momentum
could be just a taste of things to come
as generation rent
worn they're at risk of becoming
generation homeless
jason farrell sky news